let me track it down enter enter here we
go less than 30 less than 30 coming up
22 players average rating is a hefty
hefty 21:43 very high for an average
rating time handicapped ending in 30
minutes were playing for more than just
confetti here we're playing for crowns
crowns here we go here we go oh okay
that that little uh time thing is
actually a little time thing is already
in a good spot here get the Queen really
quick is that Bishop gonna be chased
away okay f7 they're gonna do a pawn
push they'll just take I have a bunch of
exchanges on that square
okay now rook to d1 my bishops gonna be
backed up soon the Knights gonna play to
b6 to hit my bishop let's back up I want
to preserve it and that bishop in I get
out of it with h3 right away capture
towards the Sun and get some play on the
a file just this they're still in a pin
still in the pin let's keep them in a
pin and I don't know what I want to do
let's go night let's go Knight do
something Knight pawn push and then get
rid of this Knight and then play here
I'm not quite sure what that's even
doing let's come back here pawn push no
Queen to b5 first okay this is a little
bit scary row no it's not it's not scary
anymore
resignation back to tournament two to a
bunch of zeros so we struck first
medicine for go oh man we're gonna have
the caro-kann okay we've played before
down to the wire down to the wire let's
hang out of that Bishop get on that d5
square get my Knight to c6 and do what
next do what next get that light square
Bishop Bishop to or a night here Bishop
to where I got to watch out for d6 or oh
no my knight on f5 is there to watch
over it rook to c8 take care a 6 b5
Knight to c4
I have this coverage I have this covered
they probably missed that they missed it
so what next okay c4 if pawn push maybe
Bishop 83 later let's try Knight to be
for like to be for or that move okay
that is a pretty interesting move now
let's do this and I really want to get
this move in it's a little bit scary but
my King is gonna have to go out and
cease f7 here f7 and let's do this I
think there's gonna be Queen here with a
knight check out one of those two
squares so let's do this Knight to f5
Knight to f5 let's go here Knight a5 and
then do what next I got a defend over
here I think got a defend over here just
defend defend defend defend defend uh-oh
I'm close to trapped I'm very very close
to trap 31 seconds defend defend oh it's
very scary it's very very scary right
here
scary town I'm in trouble trade Queens
please just raid Queens what did I do to
deserve this trade Queens run away scary
it's very very scary here we go run 14
seconds run run defense defense defense
defense how much time how much time how
much time how much time how much time
give you give a check come back is there
any time how much time how much time how
much time how much time which time come
on just run out of time
back to tournament they forfeit oh man
that was so tight 12 6 the
sky is relentless this guy is relentless
okay come on go go go go go go go
this is nutty it's nutty look out Bishop
takes tricks tricks everywhere tricks on
f7f file if I left file G file
chief file Bishop asta back up okay I'm
not quite sure what that does it's not
really in a bad pin okay
oh my Bishop's trapped okay pins let's
preserve my LightSquared bishop pins
pins pins dark squares dark squares move
Knight pileup right this is a tough pin
to get out of or is it or is it okay get
my knight around to f5 let's back up
here is the Queen close to trap she's
close to trapped not anymore I'm on c6
come back here f7 f v f7 and f5 and the
knight is dead it's soon to be dead okay
let's go f5 f5 how am i doing timewise
okay they're out of the pin I still want
to get f5 in though f5 here we go
the knight double up rooks hang on hang
on hang on
take that night or mh-6 very very soon
what am i what's the delay what's the
delay just um I really don't want to oh
I could take the rope take the rook you
okay what am i doing okay right here
take the knight a couple times get that
night out of there take the knight a
couple times take here and then here I
got this fifteen seconds right I'm on h6
h6 check bishop we're right here
oh that's bishop check I should have
done that right away okay check and then
Queen trade I have this defended while
they drop the Queen they missed it
horizontal horizontal back to turret
they resigned 2012 12 11 2012 twelve
eleven here we go
less than 24 let me close out of that
less than 24 dick aru's
he's left ok ok let's go let's go let's
go let's go come on Oh 20s 20s up there
another strong dog here another strong
one let's go Carroll save the day
exchange Carroll okay we're not having
paying off Bob Minich
not having that let's go and maybe I
should have just broken that pin let's
come back here there's gonna be Queen c2
rook to c8 Queen c2 is discouraged now
maybe I get the H file let's get off of
this I'm ok with double deaf puns they
gonna do that let's get in B 5 B 5 B 5
coming up here we go and Castle maybe I
should have taken that bishop first ok
let's do it right now and then take the
knight and then pivot my own night
somewhere else right here hitting the
Queen looking for Forks looking for
Forks here oh I missed twice they missed
it I'm on the Queen and I want to just
trade here trade Knights trade Queens
I'm on B to trade Queens oh we're gonna
have a Queen trade it's much more simple
to play if the Queens are off the board
much more simple I just have to be a
little bit careful here a little bit
careful that Queen flight square here we
go and now I get in
what next be for something with B for
here let's come over here no no no what
I hear cuz there B rook takes Queen to
g5 next Queen to g5 trade the Queen is
close to trapped ok trade again
oh there's rook move there's a rook move
to f4 let's get out of that and then my
queen is gonna have to look foolish here
let's give a check and then actually get
out of that rook move with check get out
of that little tactic my queen is a
little bit weird place right there let's
do this and then take the Queen and then
the rook
okay so this is working out I'm gonna
take towards the center and then
pinpoint the beep on next and then get
my king going
let's go King let's go King King up King
up King right here actually maybe I
stopped should have stopped the King
right there yeah I probably should have
stopped that okay that's a good move
that's a very very good move making
progress at the pond and maybe I should
I should have been doing that move okay
let's come over here and I want to get
King position it's close to me
very very close to me I got that pond at
the very least I'm getting the a pond
back and my King has a good position now
and I want to come back over here
okay seventh rank okay main threats King
over here watching over that King I want
to keep it boxed out I want to make sure
that that's secure okay they're down on
time back to term in thirty seven thirty
thirty twenty eight
I won that game didn't I win that game I
thought it was already at twenty okay I
guess not never never
lol okay Grand Prix Grand Prix d3 here
we go we've seen it before Queen h4 f5
I guess my bishops gonna get rocked back
alright let's go forward this I want to
preserve my LightSquared Bishop let's
still open up this Lane right here get
the dark scrub bishops off and then I
could take on g6 twice if my queen is on
h6 let's come back here I don't want the
Queen trade there is no pawn push I want
to keep my queen around oh no now pawn
takes I'm on the night pawn takes I'm on
the night I'm on the night I'm on the
night they might have missed it
uh-oh killer h7 aged seven this is
reasonable isn't it let's come back here
and then double up double up this is hit
a bunch of times here g6
g6 is being hit right here rook here I
take on this square or something I want
to get my knight where where do I want
to get my Knight to e4 just clear the
lane here clear the lane what am i doing
pawn push there's takes okay I have this
like I'm on the Queen and now let's get
to a seven he's seven is where I want to
be next
whit's check okay and stop that pawn
push actually look right there would
have been good okay I got to take like
this maybe it's a take okay I gotta
watch out like the dark square diagonal
dark square diagonal let's do this
check and then is this okay to do
looking for mate next it's me
very very close to it take this check I
don't have any time where's my time you
take here with the check check get my
rook oh no no oh they're being sneaky
mates soon very soon back determent they
forfeit done time forty two forty two
thirty five thirty
that guy has seven games in the top the
top guys seven games in okay
ah let's go let's go let's go let's go
'if I've Knight up support what get in
the F 5 F 4 F 5 F 4 let's do this
support my Center and then still F 5
coming up still F 5 coming up I'm on
that night twice soon right here that
might have been rook takes Knight right
there let's do this I'm on the night
again
f 3 oh that was nice that was really
really nice okay now maybe pawn push
okay they're playing very quick and
strong very quick and strong right here
I guess what do I do Wow what do I do
Knight right here f2 that's what I do f2
looking for f2 and then takes a couple
times take with the King actually this
is probably better
take that night and then push forward
burn their time I'm actually on that
pond as well and this and then pond push
I could also take here mate threat they
actually are in real big trouble I think
really big trouble this is leading to
mate leading to mate right there on g1
back to tournament 49 42 42 42 I came
back with that when I should not have
one I don't think here we go
49 42 42 never again never LOL is back
at it right here
so let's go with our open Sicilian okay
let's actually it's now like a lot let's
stop that Bishop to g4 move and now what
is this Benko gambit territory Knight c4
get Knight c4 yeah this is a Benko
gamble and then go gamble and here we go
this is a tough to play this is really
really tough to play against and I want
to get this move in but it's not so easy
it's just it's not so easy okay
yeah I got to defend my knight I want to
get this move in soon very very soon
okay I have this covered I want to get
out these moves in next pom push there's
pawn push okay let's stop that get this
in get rid of their dark square Bishop
dark square Bishop needs to go okay here
we go dark square Bishop my knight what
is my knight doing
oh I'm dropping that pond dropping that
pond okay let's defend it and then do
this how much time is left 24 Queen okay
I'll go for the Queen trade and get that
pond get this pond next Knight takes and
everything's defended and let's trade
Knights
trade nights okay I get this pawn and
then get this one next this one next
right yes I'm defending this but I have
to do
in between move in-betweener
in-betweener
okay now we have this I think three
moves play moves get behind the pond
behind the pie push push push push again
what do we have time wise this guy's
flying it's flying here okay mate
there we go back to turn right back to
terminate 56 6556 that guy's nine games
in the leader double the points double
the points darken let's get in b5
resolved the tension in the center how
will they capture okay LightSquared
Bishop out take towards the center trade
light square bishop s' build my center
if they take maybe get the h-file Bishop
d6 take care and now get a knight to the
e4 square Knight to e4 is the plan let's
keep this closed let's keep this closed
Knight to e4 coming out move move like
wasn't my night moving just then I knew
what I wanted to do for like quite some
time quite some time I knew what I
wanted to do there okay Knight could not
go like that okay let's get my queen
over on this side of the board before
their Queen does and get my rooks okay I
got to do this I think rook to f6 was
gonna be very dangerous it was gonna be
very very dangerous let's try this I
need to defend and get out of that
nonsense get out of that nonsense let's
try this very scary very very scary
right here okay a scary time scary time
right here I'm getting chased around
real bad okay now I have to defend this
pawn that rooks gonna get very active
let's come over here get the beep on
beep on quickly okay and now I need King
came to do something okay let's go let's
go let's go
Oh push pon push coming up and okay
let's do it right now and pound push
again oh they forgot about that oh they
were into too too much time pressure
right there they're less than three
they're letting their clock tick what's
going on here okay back to term in 72 83
72-54 53 less than 13 minutes less than
13 minutes I'm getting hit against a lot
of strong players here 2274 now bands
bands at three clock is ticking can't do
that that was almost a really
bad-mouthed slip almost a really bad
mouse slip right there get Queen to d2
in Queen to d2 that night is still
pinned ID is still pinned right there
it's pinned right was that that's just
missed right that's a free pond back
determine they resigned 90 that was a
quick resigner nine games Tim we played
in that five-minute game the
nimzo-indian let's do Sicilian Oh what's
going on here what is my opponent doing
okay let's come back here I don't want
to allow that and play in the center
play in the center night right here is
there's Queen Queen check same thing
going on if Knight there there's pawn
push pawn push and then well let's
support this first and now actually
night right here I should have done that
and move earlier and as a follow-up
let's go here there's also a knight
there a bishop here is not really an
issue
it's defend against this there is no
Queen takes G the bishop was blocking it
and now push this night away push the
night away
and actually I'm take here and then just
recapture I'm not going to take is the
king I'll hide behind the pond I want to
actually get a queen there induced that
pond to move and now may and to threat
vain to threatmate and one may in one
resignation resignation there's nothing
to be done
back to tournament that was a quick win
a couple quick wins back-to-back 110 103
110 103 double those points
here we go another resigner back to
tournament uh-oh 121 or 311 games in
here we go here we go what are we gonna
have okay
let's go be five okay how are we gonna
get something quick mmm no here's still
okay let's do this this should be seven
okay rook to c8 rip to c8 get a pin on
b4 and see how they respond to that
Bishop to c5 might be played real soon
d6 maybe let's do it right now and then
get my knight to the sea Foursquare real
weak spot capture like this and get on
the B file okay I'm gonna take that dark
square bishop push in the center pivot
my knight away I could have even
considered right there I should have
played h4 okay recapture now h4 next
lock down on that and then and then lock
down on f5 and then look for a 4 B 4 a 4
B 4 very very soon that night is gonna
be a killer ok let's open it up I have
to open this up really really soon the
[ __ ] is gonna give check my King Esther
run like a maniac run King run King
Oh H or a file a file ok let's take this
get to the a file really really quick
really really kicked what am I saying
mates mates it's unavoidable it's an
unavoidable it's like a fishing pole no
the bishops there to block I missed that
where's the tricks where's the tricks
let's just guard here they were ready to
smash that open over here over here just
take this and then what am i doing
Oh rook here rook right here was working
that's me I should have done that
earlier back to tournament 140 123 why
didn't I see that sooner close out okay
here we go here we go here we go here we
go here we go
efore um we might have it we might have
it happening no okay let's get rid of
that guy well let's get rid of um Bishop
d3 coming up
Bishop d3 I'm not gonna go for that
that's a bit too far-fetched right here
I should have controlled that e5 square
and I'm gonna try to just work with this
there is Bishop check but I have Bishop
check maybe in response later on I guess
I have to take that night okay let's
support this and I don't know what I
want to do next oh man oh man push that
night away push that night away get my
night doing something else get it doing
something else tonight right here it
could be very good and dropping pawns is
not good it's not good
get on h 7 h 7 h 7 h 7 h 7 is on page 7
is on let's do this first
oh I should have taken it there's gonna
be bishop block crap I should have done
that sooner
ok get the Queen where the knight is in
a pin you have to do that get out of the
pin get out of the pin get out of the
pin very soon I'm still in a pin I mean
two pins a bunch of pins I want to get
on h7 age 7 oh this is leading to mate
real soon right the King has to move
there's check and then where's the main
let's give a check here that's a start
isn't it where's the mate where's the
main give a check here is that working
what am i doing this has to be me no am
i doing check what's going on here how
many mates am I gonna miss check um
there we go
finally I've probably missed seven mates
right there 160 121 184 81 less than
seven less than seven less than seven
here we go
c5e six not so fast not so fast pawn
push you're gonna miss that as a bishop
trapped okay I have a nice Center H upon
H pun and now that aw why'd I do that
dropping it dropping it a night here is
not even working I got to get that night
out of there though
that night has to leave okay they
dropped it dropped a piece Queen 2c1
picking off the rook or at least the pun
okay let's not let's come back my
cleaners may be running out of squares
and let's get over here Castle queenside
and then this my Knights gonna be pushed
away get my knight here and then that
pun is going really really fast let's do
this I want to play rook here just stop
everything stop everything cold let's do
this and now it's not it's not the best
spot for a wreck but it's gonna buy me
some time
it's gonna buy me some time to do some
exciting stuff over here where's the
exciting stuff clean here and then
Knight coming in to where what's my
light-square bishop doing nothing it's
not doing anything and I don't know if I
want to trade rooks just yet push my pun
push this pawn oh no no no that's so
fast
push it again in the night here push
again get to this dark square but not so
fast after guard my knight Knight here
coming up and then Knight here let's
come here King to b8 came to be a okay
now oh I made it's a mouse look my Queen
was hanging my queen was oh man be very
scared be very very scared oh man that
was a wrong Knight move oh man oh
they're going crazy they're going crazy
that's me that's me that's made back to
tournament 180 180 141
we both have 14 games in less than five
less than five come on stick with it
crowns clowns let's go let's go let's go
let's go listing 5 less than 5 come on
come on ah man that would have been
brutal that would have been brewed if
they took my queen
all three rooks take those free rooks
resignation is this a trap is this a
trap get that night out of there so I
could get the other night let's let's
just let's block that night
- move move knight move Knight and then
Bishop - where okay that Knights gone
and then hit the Queen hit the knight
get that night out of there Bishop here
if the knight goes there whether or not
goes there here we go
trades war trades the Queen's are coming
off or are they queenside castle okay
rook to e1 things are still good
deadly discovered attacks deadly
discovered attacks there's no good
solution here right back to tournament
they resigned 200 100 200 161 103 again
this is the third time I'm playing
against this guy never lol never
lol okay another exchange caro-kann
another exchange caro-kann here okay
that is a bit of a note of an annoying
move okay that Knights gonna play there
let's do this my LightSquared bishop is
dead but now it's not bishop g6
take towards the center i want to get
out of this pin really soon let's try
this I'm in trouble let's do this Oh
why'd I do that there was a knight
oh man that would have been really
really really bad really really bad I
could have been right there okay let me
take this and then okay that pot is
falling that pond is definitely falling
the rooks on the the seventh right here
pigs one pig so far one pig another pig
is coming okay chase that rook away
chase that rook away chase the other
rook away get this pun now my queen is
in a better position push this guy chase
the Queen away B to get B to get a two
I'm on the rook I'm on the rook push
this guy over here get my queen to f3
I'm on h3 and maybe there's something
well let's do this first check get over
here rook to be to I want to keep this
rook around to watch over what to watch
over the f2 square let's come back here
I'm on h3 again Age 3 again rook takes I
can take on b2 and I'm gonna go for this
actually even though it might not be
best I'm gonna go for
let's go I get on the seventh it's the
second rake for the second ranked first
and let's stop this I want to stop right
there in fact okay let's do this
if the rook was still there I couldn't
do that rook lift let's get behind the
past pot I don't have any time where's
my time where's my time I don't have any
time here no no no no no no no no no no
oh they missed it check let's come back
here ah okay come on right here pre
moves
Primo's mr. rook mate all right it's not
a mate but look check take what's the
count what's the count how much time how
much time how much time how much time go
back to chairmat they're down on time to
2181 that is probably sealing it unless
there's like two wins two or three wins
in a row one minute and three one minute
and three let's go here
okay fantasy variation no oh what's that
I didn't mean to move that pun I really
didn't mean to do that okay
oh man okay I could take here I could
take here and maybe it's alright open up
like this and get in okay that night has
a great square but I'm gonna have to
work with it I have to work with that
night okay maybe not okay I get here
there might just okay give a check and
then do this something right here I'm on
this look against g7 take my bishop give
me a past pun and then get on d6 or get
out of checks first let's do this
there's gonna be rip takes I could take
this and now my d6 three times I'm on
the knight pawn push around the rook
here we go
4x 40s first I'm gonna take it that's 40
crowns confetti all right close shop did
the best I could
did the best I could
clothes are actually not close to 2201
137 122 good games